hey what's up i'm going to fill my
reaction to president obama's job speech
so here it is the president of the
united states i am sending this congress
a plan that you should pass right away
it's called the American Jobs Act you
should pass this jobs plan right away
it's a balanced plan that would reduce
the deficit right now Warren Buffett
pays a lower tax rate than his secretary
an outrage he has asked us to fix so we
can reduce this deficit pay down our
debt and paid for this job plan in the
process these are real choices that
we've got to make and I'm pretty sure I
know what most Americans would choose I
want to see folks in South Korea driving
Fords all of this bill made in America
and everything in this bill will be paid
for everything II every proposal I've
laid on tonight is the kind that's been
supported by Democrats and Republicans
Democrats and Republicans the Democrats
and Republicans every proposal I've laid
out tonight will be paid til Washington
that doing nothing is not an option
tweets flying back and forth no more
earmarks no more bridges to nowhere
there's a bridge that needs repair
between Ohio and Kentucky in fact this
larger notion but the only thing we can
do to restore prosperity is just
dismantle government let everyone write
their own rules and tell everyone
they're on their own it's not who we are
it's not the story of America very much
well hi